Somebody's bound to at some point, what do you guys think chat GPT this that and the rest we are just like you guys playing with it having fun with it excited about it.
Just be careful that with chat GPT that you see what Google, Google's most updated terms of service are on AI generated content because I know, based on talking to a really close friend of mine that is in this industry thickly thickly
is not a word but very thick he's been doing this since the internet was around.
And a couple of you guys were actually in that meeting with me when he had this.
But he said that either the day before the day after Google very coincidentally and very quietly updated their terms of service, and said that anything that resembles AI generated content is not allowed blah blah blah blah blah.
Now, that was a couple months ago. Six weeks ago, has that changed. I don't know, because I'm not using chat GPT yet.
Although I'm very excited about the possibilities. Do I think chat GPT is going to ruin this business model. No, I do not. Do I think that it's going to change it, of course it is right, of course it is, but I'm excited about the change I'm excited
because man do I hate content, and it's kind of going to level the playing field.
If it's allowed, and if we can figure out ways it's allowed but guys, the only thing I would tell you is, I don't recommend doing things, you know, manually just for the sake of doing it manually, but sometimes doing the thing that other people are not willing to do
is the very reason or way that you outdo everybody. Okay. And so, I have one, I have made so much money by spending time and getting good at writing content so that I could then go and hire people to write content, so that I could check it.
So then I could then hire a project manager who could then hire a VA that could write content so that I didn't have to touch it.
But I initially learned how to write content guys for my first 30, this is not recommended but for my first 30 Legion properties. Every bloody word on those websites, I wrote, I wrote on my keyboard on my MacBook Air, the thin MacBook Air in 2016.
It was like the base model of the base model slower than tar. You have a few pictures on there that things slow as heck 13 inch screen, I wrote 30,000 30 websites, and I had between five and 10,000 words of content on every one of those websites, do the math.
Okay, that's how I learned how to do content so well. And I hate it. I hate every second of it's not fun for me. Okay, but again, you know why I do it because I don't have to. It's something I can do.
I can put on my website, and if it's good and it ranks, I'm going to get paid again and again and again for content that I wrote five years ago.